hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again in
season 11 has just recently ended I
believe it ended today if not last night
so we're gonna be talking about this
the rewards you're gonna be getting the
Vikings did win of course if you want a
little TL DR it's pretty obvious that
that was gonna happen but yeah we're
gonna be talking about the emblem and
then the outline as well as the
ornaments that are faction based that
you will be getting regardless of what
you know whatever you happen to be
everyone's gonna get something just
might not be the greatest thing in the
world but yeah as long as like the view
enjoy guys subscribe for new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes to hear
updates the fan shots on the leaks if
it'll be kept us today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
and never miss out in an update that fee
subscribe to the channel and with that
let's get started you have a first up we
have the outline and just in case you
are new to the game I always do this
with every single season I have to
update people on how this stuff works so
basically you're gonna see on my screen
that this is gold now every single
person for the outline specifically
every single person is going to be able
to get this right so no matter what
faction you're a part of it you're going
to be getting this outline it's just in
a different color so if we go back to
what I said the Vikings who won the
faction war are gonna get this in gold
the samurai if they are in second place
will get it in silver and then whoever's
in last place is going to get this in
bronze so you'll notice on my screen
it's gold meaning on part of the Vikings
not like I said everybody can get this
it's the same exact design nothing has
changed just the color I just wanted to
update everybody just so that everyone's
aware is because it can get very
confusing and I still get a lot of
comments about that but yeah as you can
see it's a pretty decent outline not too
bad I'm definitely [ __ ] with this you
know we got some bone little shards on
the left and right there not really sure
but those are got a little like black
engravings on the thing as well so they
have been decorated they're tied to the
overall shield and there's a lot of rope
on the top and the bottom tying stuff
together
very nice piece personally there's a lot
of different you know there's a lot of
unique outlines in this game and
personally in my opinion this isn't the
best one it's also not the worst one but
in my opinion even with the gold book
it's pretty average I would say this
might fit well with the silver tone but
I'm unaware of what that looks like
next up we have the ornaments and these
are going to be faction based demeaning
the Knights the Vikings the Samer
and the Wulin will get the same name of
the ornament but they're going to be
slightly different and slightly skewed
recently the past ornaments that we've
gotten our most are usually faction
based so that's usually the norm for the
ornaments now just in case you're
unaware but the way that the faction war
works in terms of ornaments is that only
the winning team can get these ornaments
so in this case if you're part of the
Viking faction and you didn't switch
midseason or anything like that you've
been of if you've been a Viking since
before campaign one of this season you
will be able to get these ornaments and
you can use them for any character even
if they happen to be of a different
faction than than than the Vikings a lot
of people think that if whoever wins
only gets the ornaments for the Viking
characters that's why people who play
samurai play on the samurai faction no
you get the ornaments for every
character in the roster but you have to
be a part of the Viking faction if
you're part of the Knights faction like
on my xbox account I cannot use these
hopefully that cleared everything up so
let's start to get into this for the for
the night one we have I'm gonna be
showing the trusty warden here this is
going to be the default piece you're
gonna be noticing very similar
similarities between all four of these
pieces like usual like I said cuz
they're faction based that's some giant
wings going on here it's looking pretty
cool going to the Vikings once again I'm
pretty sure that's just the sea serpent
I think I'm noticing that the trend here
I believe these are snakes and serpents
we've got the snail tail I know the
snails body going all the way to the
back of the Vikings head got some
smaller pieces on the side but it's
really trying to show off that the main
piece of the ornament is the snake in
the middle which isn't too bad but
honestly not really my favorite
next one we have is for the samurai and
honestly as you're seeing on screen if
you take a look right now you'll see
that that is the ornament for winning
season 11 but I have Ken say on so if
you check the bottom right of the
ornaments list the ones that say 3000 if
you look at the one on the bottom right
they actually have like very similar if
not the exact same like side plates I
don't really know what to call those
that's what I just kind of noticed when
I got that so it might have just been
like a copy-paste of it but once again
the snake is very you know - protruding
out in the middle you can change that
bottom color to blue whatever happens to
be your color of your outfit once again
same for the other two overall not too
bad but definitely wouldn't be wearing
it on my care
or anytime soon next up we got the Wulin
and honestly it's happened twice this
like twice in a row in my opinion but
the faction that isn't even in the
faction war has the best faction
ornament I don't really know how that
makes any sense but like the woollen
just have some pretty decent ornaments
and this is one of those as well now
once again it's gonna fall into the same
category of its I not great I'm probably
never gonna use this but out of the four
I definitely got to say that this is my
favorite the other three are pretty
bland and then lastly we have the emblem
and a recap for this stuff I believe
every single person can get this so even
if you're the last fat you know they're
the worst faction this season or the
Viking any faction whatever it happens
to be I believe that you can unlock this
emblem so they're not a great emblem not
really sure where you would put this in
your fashion bill but it's there if you
need yeah and that's really it guys let
me know what you guys think about the
stuff in the comments below honestly
it's not too great I think this season
we kind of got [ __ ] over with the
ornaments in my opinion I've noticed the
quality getting uh you know a little bit
worse as we go on you know what this
year with the seasons but maybe we'll
pick it up next season and might like I
said in my opinion these aren't great bi
Congrats to the Vikings for one in the
faction or more like your 10 out of 12
or some [ __ ] I don't know what you guys
what your record is on but yeah congrats
there but yeah and then the next couple
weeks we're gonna be getting a Halloween
teaser I believe next week is the
Halloween event is when it starts so
that's going to be cool and then at the
end of this month we're gonna be getting
a little bit of some shaky teasers for
the season twelve character the Wulin
which is gonna be very very exciting and
the four people that are gonna be
commenting about the leaks and how it
got leaked already I saw it it's not
worth making a video we can't even see
his face and I'm pretty sure half of
that is straight-up lies hey guys if you
guys did enjoy the video definitely be
sure to leave the like subscribe if
you're new I cover the informational
side a foreigner that being the balance
changes to hear updates the Patchett's
and the leaks if it would be kept up to
date with everything happening within
the world of Warner and ever miss out on
an update that be subscribe the channel
hi guys take care and I'll see you for
tomorrow because I got a little special
video planned
you